non mais qu'est ce qui va faire et pas
très loin la gamme un fou sa mère marie
bockel la caméra hawk et labrosse
[Rires]
troisième essai et en plus si tu es une
banale encore maman troisième essai mais
toi sur les damiers la flamme solaire de
balle assez bien j'ai pas longue
l'acacia et comédie mais avant soi même
ou alors il faut que je mette plus là
bas aussi tuveri là les poubelles devant
[Rires]
rien le nombre de matchs de foot on est
chez par une poubelle ça mais c'est
passé à ça une fois mais ça c'est sûr et
je passe oui je le tente ou pas ce que
tu as toujours espoir oui mais oui de la
cage regardera pas malheureusement dans
lequel benoît dolle mois d'août il n'est
pas réglementaire le ballon le ballon
des sirènes préparer les ventes euros
à bâle aura pas c'est pas l'envié m'a
passé
[Applaudissements]
sega des matches
tagada